the double bond is karol Angiers
biography of jewish italian writer and
holocaust survivor
primo la vie she spoke at the 92nd
Street Y in New York City for an hour
well it's wonderful to be here and it's
wonderful to see so many people here
today I mean at eleven o'clock on a
Sunday morning I think it shows how
widely read and widely loved primo Lavy
is here in in the United States as he
also is in in England and I think that
is what he wanted it's what every writer
wants readers but prima lady wanted them
more than most I think because he was
essentially a lonely man who found
personal contact difficult at the same
time he needed it desperately and I
think his solution was writing but I
think I'm getting a bit ahead of myself
here and I'll tell you what what I what
I want to do today first of all I'm
going to assume that you know the basics
about primo la vie that he was a chemist
that he was an Italian and a Jew that he
was captured as a partisan in 1943 and
deported to Auschwitz as a Jew that he
survived and wrote one of the great
books on that subject if this is a man
which is called survival in Auschwitz
here in the states that he then went on
to write other wonderful books of which
the best-known are probably the truth
the story of his return the periodic
table his chemist's autobiography and
perhaps the drowned and the saved which
is collections of essays again on
Holocaust themes he wrote many other
books as well two novels for example
collections of poetry and of scientific
philosophical fables and wonderful
quirky stories and essays all equally
original
all full his unique combination of
intellectual passion and scientific
observation and ironic humor I'm going
to assume you all know this and anyhow
you do now have you been didn't before
um and I'm going to assume that you know
about his death and about the questions
raised by it and that you were touched
by it as all his readers were so
assuming this basic knowledge I'm first
of all going to talk in a bit more
detail about his life and work or as it
must be in his case about his life and
death and work and then secondly I'm
going to say a bit about my biography
itself because its structure is unusual
its double in fact as its title
indicates and it includes several short
chapters in which I appear myself some
reviewers have disliked this I've
disliked it myself in some other
biographies in which of course it's not
as well done as it isn't mine but but
this is the direction I think in which
biography is going as it becomes less
naive and more self-critical so after
primo Levy's life and death and work I
shall say something very briefly about
my book and why it has the shape it has
alright well there's really one main
thing that I want to say about each of
primo Levy's life and death and work I
hope that he would agree about them all
of them now that he is dead indeed I
think he would because he was starting
to say them himself towards the end but
most of what he said for most of his
life especially in public went in the
opposite direction
the only thing about which everything
that he said points in the same
direction as my conclusions was his
death or rather the depression which
caused it
now let's begin with with his work the
one thing that everyone knows about
primo la vie is that he was a chemist
because he himself told us so often and
always when his first great a schvitz
book was published in 1947 by a small
publishing house and then disappeared he
told everyone that he was content he had
done his duty to the dead he had
testified and he went back to his real
work chemistry and he thought no more
about writing all through his writing
life he insisted that his real work was
chemistry in 1975 he published that
chemists autobiography the periodic
table in which each chapter as I'm sure
you know is named after a chemical
element in 1976 he gave a major
autobiographical talk in Turin about
being a chemist who became a writer by
accident it was called los cretur a
non-secretor the non writer writer now
what I discovered was that none of this
was true that's an exaggeration
I mean primo baby was it's true that he
was a chemist he trained as a chemist at
university and he worked as a chemist
all his life as the technical director
in fact of a paint and varnish Factory
he was one of 30 or 40 world experts in
insulating varnish for copper wire and
it was true the chemistry was at the
heart of much of his writing and it
provided him with a whole world of
extraordinary images and experiences to
draw on which gave him an unfair
advantage over every other writer he
always said but everything that he said
about the primacy of chemistry
in his life and especially in his
ambitions and desires was false he had
dreamed about becoming a full-time
writer from the start if survival in
Auschwitz had been successful straight
away when it wasn't successful straight
away he doggedly took it back to a now D
that's the great cheer in publisher four
or five times over the next ten years
when a now D finally published it in
1958 and it began to gain a huge
audience straightaway
his dreams of retiring from chemistry
immediately returned he was split like a
centaur as he always said between
chemistry and writing but painfully
longing always to escape and to to
mutate from the from the chemists
caterpillar to the writer butterfly and
fly away when he gave that talk the non
writer writer in 1976 he had already
been semi-retired as a chemist for two
whole years and the truth is that for
all the 29 years between 1948 and 1977
when he fully retired from his chemical
factory he gave every spare minute to
writing when he looked back on this
double life afterwards he was amazed he
couldn't understand how he had done it
it's a mystery he said and this had
begun long before 1948 as a small child
and as a schoolboy he wrote poems at
university and immediately after in the
years before Auschwitz he was a great
storyteller he loved telling stories one
of which he wrote down as soon as he
returned and it became the first story
in his first collection story and
naturally Natural History's in 1941
that's two years before his arrest and
deportation he wrote two stories which
would go into the periodic table in
1940's two to three he wrote a long
story called wall ma man which he never
published but which I eventually found
and which shows that he had begun to ask
his lifelong question what is a man
even before Ashford's then as soon as he
returned he wrote not only survival in
Auschwitz itself but he began the sequel
the truce straight away immediately and
he only gave it up because of the
failure of survival in Auschwitz which
deeply disappointed him he also started
writing short stories straight away and
published them straight away all through
the 1940s and 50s and writing and
eventually publishing poetry as well
although poetry was his most private
writing in which he was least in control
in other words the myth of primo Lavy
the chemist who came to writing by
accident because he fell into the worst
Inferno of the 20th century and who very
likely would never have written at all
if this had not happened that myth
carefully presented by primo levy
himself is false
writing was central and necessary to him
and had been from very early on and not
just writing but publishing his campaign
to republish his first book his
determination to publish his stories and
poetry from the start his intention at
the end to publish his last unfinished
book which contained a very painful
agonized self-examination all these
things show that primo levy was the
opposite of an accidental non writer
writer on the contrary he was a
dedicated and even ruthless writer
putting his family life second to his
writing
putting his friends second to writing
about them to using them in his lifelong
exploration of what it meant to be human
he did this for example to his best
friend in Auschwitz Alberto de la Volta
whom he used to show that even the most
courageous and intelligent person would
tell himself lies for love this is
because Alberto who faces the truth
about the crematoria sooner and more
steadily than anyone else immediately
denies it when his own father is
selected he did it to the Italian
bricklayer Lorenzo Corona who saved his
life
in Auschwitz showing us that the
greatest moral hero could also be a poor
uneducated drunken and derelict man he
did it to one of his best friends before
Auschwitz Sandro Del Mastro his family
were furious about it he did it used him
hit the person in his work I mean to his
best friend on the return journey from
Auschwitz whom he used as a model for
Cesare the great hero of the truth and
chase it or the real chase that it was
very angry about it himself he even did
it to his first great love in the
periodic table there's a wonderful
chapter called phosphorus about this
young woman and in it there's a
gloriously funny episode in which she
threatens to blackmail him into walking
her home from the cinema by screaming
out by shouting out that he's molesting
her now this she told me 50 years later
was not true she said I was a naughty
girl but I wasn't that naughty
so when primo Navy showed her the story
she asked him to take that bit out
but he said it showed her character
better than anything that had happened
and although he loved her all his life
and she begged him he refused to remove
it so what was going on here
why did primo levy conceal how important
writing was to him we've stumbled upon a
crack in his public image as soon as we
really look at it now the truth is that
primo levy constructed his public image
not so much deliberately as
instinctively on the basis of the image
he presented to the world all his life
but all his life this image was not true
it was one of several containing
structures that he had built to protect
and defend himself his family was one
his work in the factory was one and this
being a non writer writer was another he
built this image as I say on the one
that he had already presented to friends
his teachers his fellow prisoners and
Auschwitz that of a calm quiet utterly
ordinary man
in fact from childhood on he'd been the
opposite of all these things hyper
sensitive deeply disturbed and the
opposite of ordinary isolated from
everyone around him because despite his
best efforts he was a genius he
pretended that he wasn't because he
found the isolation unbearable and
because or perhaps as a result of this
he had an absolute passion for equality
and he couldn't bear the idea that
anyone especially himself would stand
out be favored or privileged above
anyone else
primo levy was the least charismatic and
the most modest of geniuses who would
never ever stand out from the crowd
but underneath I came to understand he
was secretly highly ambitious and
competitive as a boy
for example he dreamed of making a
fundamental contribution to science and
as a writer he always tried to do in
fact he always did what had never been
done before as a man he hated to be out
shown by anyone else intellectually
because his intellect was the only part
of himself that either he or anyone else
had ever valued he had huge ambition but
he repressed and denied it and he had a
correspondingly huge fear of failure so
all of these added together produced the
non writer writer the writer who did not
admit to being one because he was
ashamed of his ambition and because he
was afraid to fail all right well this
answer only rear Aizaz the question why
was he like this what was going on and
so we come to our second subject which
is primo Levy's life
primo lady is a man I suppose there
whereas there must be for anyone two
main factors in the shaping of primo
Levy's character his public experience
on the one hand history and his private
one so we could sum those up as the
public experience would be Turan fascism
a schvitz and his family as the private
experience especially his original
family and his inheritance from them now
I'm not going to go into the history of
fascism in Italy here you'll be glad to
hear or in particular into the history
of the racial laws which most Cellini
passed in 1938 when primo levy was 19
you can imagine for yourselves the
impact that these laws which may Jews
into non persons would have on a boy
already isolated by his genius he
difference but not so far by his
Jewishness because of the deep
acceptance and assimilation of Jews in
Italy the racial laws first alerted him
to what would become a central subject
of his life after he experienced its
logical conclusion in Auschwitz and that
is the problem of how we respond to
difference how we treat those who are
different from ourselves in color or
religion or race his reaction to the
racial laws at 19 showed the courage and
the moral fiber
that was beneath his mild obliging
exterior they made him proud of his
difference and they confirmed him in his
opposition to every form of tribalism
for the rest of his life
even the tribalism of his own tribe the
Jews primo la vie was the ultimate
individualist and outsider deeply
attached to his country and to Jewish
traditions sorry to see those
diminishing in Italy as they have done
since the war but never able to belong
entirely to anything and determined to
warn those who do of the dangers of
belonging well I said I wouldn't go into
the racial laws and now I have a bit but
I really will not go into the subject of
Auschwitz it is too large a subject and
besides I think that a schvitz doesn't
form anyone it only destroys and that an
extreme experience like that of a
concentration camp doesn't change you it
only throws you back on your deepest and
most essential qualities as like a storm
that blows topsoil off a landscape and
exposes the rock beneath primo la vie
got through Auschwitz in the way that he
got through
everything in life before and after by
suppressing his emotional reactions and
relying on the strongest parts of
himself his intellect and his will the
trouble was that this worked extremely
well for one year of mortal danger but
less well for 66 years of ordinary life
which is I suppose my main thesis about
him
to which we'll return so this leaves
amongst the historical influences on
primo la vie his city Turin and I must
say that one of the great discoveries of
my research period my two years of
living and working in in Turin was the
city itself and I think that this is one
of the ways in which biography can
uncontroversially contribute to our
understanding of a writer so you cannot
understand primo la vie unless you
understand you're in and very few people
outside Italy or even inside Italy
understand or know sure in that is in
fact the point about it it is a
secretive City which keeps its treasures
and its troubles to itself all that most
of us know about him I think is Fiat
and we if we think of it ever we think
of it like Detroit for example and I
don't know whether anyone from Detroit
is here but do we go to Detroit as
tourists no so almost no one goes to
cheer in but it is in fact a beautiful
and Noble eighteenth-century city with
exquisite boulevards and squares and the
snow-capped Alps rising behind it and
the river PO running through it but the
point about cheerin for students are
primo la vie anyway is less its beauty
than its melon clay Turin is right up in
the northwest corner of Italy and its
climate and its atmosphere are
positively British it is rainy and foggy
and cold it's people are much like some
old-fashioned stereotype of English
people or possibly Scottish people they
are hardworking high-minded cautious and
taciturn and if I as I have said Mellon
clay their humour is dry and ironic
they're very private and reserved they
tend to science instead of the arts and
they tend to loneliness and depression
for which they refuse to take either
drugs or psychoanalysis because they're
deeply suspicious of both of these
things and they prefer to soldier on
grimly on their own and there you have
prima lady prima lady was what Italians
call a Tory nays DC motor inna is a most
tyrannies tyrannies but he took
historian azita to extremes in him hard
work became workaholism a
high-mindedness became impossible ideals
and reserve became secrecy and
melancholy became full-blown cyclical
depression from which he suffered all
his life in the end
became so bad that he did take drugs and
psychoanalysis as well but it was too
late he did commit suicide
I'm sadly convinced of that and I offer
the evidence in my book and in this too
he was entirely Turin ease the Chinese
novelist Giovanni RP no calls Turin a
fatal city in which writers commit
suicide
Emilio Salieri cheese adapt a visa prima
Navy but of course not all cheer anis
commit suicide thank heaven mmm or
suffer from full-blown clinical
depression
so the question still remains why was he
like this well there is never any
complete answer to this question we know
but to get anywhere further with it I
think we need to turn from the macros
story to the micro story so from history
to the family in which we all actually
live so that is therefore what I do in
my book though it wasn't easy as you
might imagine from what I've told you
about Turin and with all of primo Levy's
relatives as super tyrannies as he was
his widow would not speak to me nor his
children nor his sister but his cousins
did his last surviving aunt and many or
all of his very close friends including
three women with whom he had close and
intimate friendships although perhaps
not affairs which is part of the story
from them and from his own writings and
interviews I pieced together his
personal story which comes as close to
illuminating the roots of his work as
anything can in my view now again of
course I can only sum up very briefly
what I learned but I learned first that
depression and suicide were very likely
in his genes
as he also said in you in fact his
paternal grandfather had committed
suicide at 39 so had his great-uncle
although Primo Navy didn't in fact know
that at only 27
his own mother primo Levy's own mother
may also have tended to depression
I learned secondly that his parents
marriage was a very difficult one his
father chazar him was a traveler a bon
vivant and a lover of life which in
Italian means a lover of women his
mother
Rena was fabulously stationary she never
left urine or at least Piedmont in her
whole life
and she was entirely inexperienced and
Victorian that was prima lady's own word
for it in his lost unpublished book in
her attitudes to sex and love Cesare had
a mistress throughout their marriage
rena suffered endured and punished him
these two models it seemed to me became
the two halves of primo Levy's own mind
the immobile self-denying sufferer
expressing itself in the man and the
adventurer traveler and lover of life in
the work now I know that this is all
terribly Freudian and eat Apple and I
hasten to add that I am a Jewish mother
myself but it lasts it simply seemed to
me to be true from all my researches
that the deepest root of prima ladies
problems was his mother
she approved of him only so long as he
was not like his father she dominated
him all his life
and would not let him go he brought his
wife home to live in her house she
brought up his children and she
dominated them all the tragedy of primo
Levy's marriage because after its
triumphant beginning in which Lucia
lavey basically saved his life by
falling in love with him after that
triumphant beginning it became slowly
but surely a tragedy for both of them
and that tragedy that tragedy came from
this central ultra Jewish ultra Italian
he had the double whammy unbroken
unhappy bond between primo lady and his
mother it was to protect himself from
her very powerful character her
dominating character that he first
developed I think that calm impenetrable
mask which he made him seem old already
as a little boy and it was to protect
himself from her that he split himself
in two
dividing off his emotional instinctive
selfish lower half from his rational and
moral higher half and trying to express
only ever the higher half the second one
in his life and his writing it didn't
always work even in his writing
especially in his poetry for example and
in some of his stories a dark maddened
force tries to break out but mostly it
did work in his writing and that is what
gives us his superhumanly
humane and just meditations on the
Holocaust and his beautiful humorous
intellectually passionate essays and
stories about chemistry and language
animals atoms and places and people so
we his readers benefit absolutely and
enormous Li from this fracture this
split in primal a V for which we must
paradoxically thank his terrible mother
and perhaps we should say that he too
benefited from it because he managed to
live a rewarding creative life on only
intellect and will for many many years
but really he only just survived it
primo Levy's imprisonment in only half
of himself the rational half of himself
made the writer especially of survival
in Auschwitz but it destroyed the man it
made him incapable of defending himself
except by endurance like his mother
it made him incapable of expressing
spontaneous love or hate or anger
it made him repressed and depressed and
in the end it killed him it gave us the
books but that was the price that he
paid well this takes us I guess to our
last primo lady subject which is his
death I have already said that I am
certain it was suicide
for reasons I explained in the book now
the most important of them is this that
in all his most serious depressions for
example the one immediately after
Auschwitz the one previous to his death
that was in 1982 and then the one the
last one in 1986 to seven in all of
these and others as well
he thought obsessively of suicide three
days before he died he said it again to
one of his close women friends he said
pins are so low a supreme army
I think only of killing myself
but people say he left no note and that
violent death that broken body at the
foot of the stairs was so out of
character he would never have done it
that way they say he was a chemist
after all he he he would have known what
pills to take how many but all that
these arguments show is that prima lady
did not plan to commit suicide he did
not decide to commit suicide and carry
out his decision in character more or
less in full possession of himself that
he would not have done the suicide
deniers are right about that prima lady
disapproved of suicide he thought it was
letting people down
and he thought it was against the aims
of life which was his only religion so
he would not have made up his mind to
commit suicide and then sat down to
explain to his family why he was doing
this to them he did not want to do this
to them or mean or plan to do this to
them
I think we can be certain of that he had
resisted his impulses to suicide before
in the previous depressions many times
and I think he was doing that again I
think from everything that his friends
told me that he was hanging on he was
trying to believe that this depression
would pass as all the others had done
and then for some reason or perhaps for
no reason an impulse caught him and he
gave in it could have happened in an
earlier depression it could have
happened in a later one it happened to
happen in this one I think we will never
know this 100% for certain because there
was no witness to the deed itself but I
think that the evidence sadly is as
strong as it can be in such cases
the question therefore is not whether a
primo lady committed suicide as why he
did was it because of Auschwitz because
of recurrence of his memories of
Auschwitz as the newspaper said at the
beginning when it happened and as people
have echoed ever since was it as Ruth
Feldman wrote Ruth Feldman was the
English translator of primo Levy's poems
she wrote in a poem of her own
despite her wishful thinking survivors
only appear to have survived was that
the reason once again there is no proof
but once again it seems to me that the
evidence is very strong prima lady
killed himself because he was in a
clinical depression but a schvitz
memories of Auschwitz were not the cause
of that depression he said so himself
only a week or so before he died to one
of his oldest and closest friends and
all of his closest friends are convinced
that was true he had testified he had
transformed unjust suffering into
knowledge and understanding and the
poison of Auschwitz he said himself no
longer ran in his veins in fact he said
more about this question very bravely
and honestly he said that Ash wits had
been his University that it had been his
time in technicolor when he was most
alert and most certain of what he had to
do of course it was the most destructive
experience anyone could have of course
it gave him nightmares for years and it
changed the way he looked at the world
forever but it was also the opposite
especially as time went on in recalling
all the horror for him and for every one
who suffered it still the central and
paradoxical and painful truth about
primo Levy's life I think
seems to me to be this that in the end
for him ash wits was also and I
emphasize also a positive experience it
gave him a reason to live which he had
not always had before it gave him a
moral requirement to write and it gave
him the subject for the fundamental
contribution to human knowledge that he
had dreamed of making as a boy it was in
the ultimate degradation of Auschwitz
that he realized and we read this in the
great central chapter of survival in
Auschwitz the canto of Ulysses it was
there that he realized most clearly the
true nobility of math that man was made
to pursue virtue and knowledge as Dante
said and it was in Auschwitz it was
there in that ultimate degradation that
he felt himself most a man because that
half of himself the rational and moral
human High human half remained alive as
it was able to do in very few so before
and after Auschwitz being half a man the
rational half of a man only was not
enough and prema Levy said that himself
he said I had wanted that too without
achieving it to be myself more more
complete or a whole man but in Auschwitz
it was enough it was more than enough so
the central and painful and paradoxical
truth about prema la vie I think is that
he was depressed before and after
Auschwitz but not in it and that he
thought of suicide many times before and
after Auschwitz but not in it the truth
is that depression and suicide were in
him from the start it is even possible
that without the experience of surviving
Auschwitz in without especially the
mission for the rest of his life to
testify to it to understand and reported
they might have claimed him sooner I
think
right that is what I wanted to say about
primo la vie now just the few words
about my book about him I promise I'll
be brief um you'll see or I hope some of
you will see that it has a strange
structure there are 15 numbered and I'm
afraid often rather long chapters of
standard biography as it were with
ordinary biographical titles like
chemistry 1937 to 1941 that kind of
title but then there are also 11 short
unnumbered chapters with different kinds
of titles and these titles are also
italicized in order to mark their
difference yeah this time I can actually
answer the question what is going on I
had a problem and after time I also had
an idea and the two came together in
this strange solution now after what
I've told you I think you'll probably be
able to guess what the problem was primo
Levy's life had been tragic and painful
and it had been tragic and painful for
his family as well and I know that they
would rather it not be told and amongst
those people who did tell it to me in
the end were several who asked not to be
identified partly because of the problem
of the family including especially the
two women who were the secret sharers of
his last 20 years now I'm not going to
go into arguments here about whether I
should have written the book at all
although if anybody wants to ask me this
question afterwards I'll do my best I
decided that it should be told but how
given that much of it was secret and
from secret sources and that's when I
had the idea these things were secret
and hidden repressed in primo Levy's
life as well they were the things that
he had cut off and repressed from
himself the rationale is hurrah sorry
the Arash
emotional things love and hate no love
and desire conflict and hate and
violence and anger all of these things
so perhaps they not only could but
should appear in my book in the same
repressed and secret way so precisely in
small secret chapters without notes
sometimes with false names which could
be told in a different and more indirect
way so that is what I did and I put into
these small secret chapters the people
who could not be named and the stories
which could not be told in the normal
open openly sourced way stories for
example of his parents marriage of his
own marriage of his troubles with women
and his conflicts with men and the story
above all most important of all of his
depressions which was the most important
and most secret thing in his life
until the end and I tell these in a less
normal for biography sort of more
irrational way for example I used two
novels that were written by people close
to the family and also through my own
encounters with one of his friends for
example with several of his loves and
with one of his enemies and so far I
think people have been most interested
in his loves but I would like to point
out that pre m'lady
repressed hate in himself even more than
love and therefore his enemy and how he
dealt with his enemy is just as
important right well I think I must stop
I I never want to stop when I start on
primal AV so I think that might explain
the seven hundred and thirty pages but
before I stop I just like to say this
very briefly that reading and
researching primo Levy's life I kept
coming across recurring images that
seemed to repeat in his life and work
and which therefore repeat in my book
there were first of all the images of
chemistry that was the main thing the
image especially of the double bond
which is the title of his lost
unpublished book and which I've borrowed
for mine
now this title had a double meaning for
him and a multiple meaning for me which
I explained in my book but the main one
is also the double meaning which he
intended because it seemed to me to sum
up the central truth about him now I
have to say that however hard I tried I
never managed to understand chemistry
but I hope that I did understand
um the primo Levy's chemistry because
the way that primo LaVey uses chemistry
and his work it is of course not hard
science he minds chemistry for metaphors
and symbols of human life so I will
follow him in this and if there are any
chemists in the audience I warn you
right now that they're going to think
this isn't very accurate chemistry
however it's approximately right the
double bond the double bond refers to
the bonds between molecules
now the bonds between inorganic
molecules are characteristically not
always but characteristically single so
that inorganic substances they form the
molecules form long stable chains but in
organic matter molecules have double
bonds therefore they are they form much
more complex rich structures but they
are also much more unstable structures
which can be broken down and destroyed
much more easily now this image of life
as it were seems to me precisely and
seemed to him the perfect image of how
life appeared to primo La Vie so rich
and creative but unpredictable full of
risk and danger and then there was the
other meaning of the Italian phrase in
Tokyo a gamma which we have another word
in English and that is the double bind
now you probably know all about this
it's a term in psychology and it means
an unwinnable situation and the probably
the most famous example of it is the
Jewish mother joke right now it's about
the Jewish mother who gives her son to
ties for Christmas at Christmas I'm
saying
Freudian slip uh for his birthday and
the next day he comes to her very
proudly wearing one of the ties and she
says to him so what's wrong with the
other one that's a double bond okay the
reason that prima lady chose this title
in Tokyo legally this double meaning was
for this metaphorical double meaning as
it were that life the double bond for
Primo levy was an unwinnable situation a
double bind there were a couple of other
images like dancing which kept coming up
in his life seemed to stand for physical
ease that he'd never had there was image
of this great split in him which I've
described and the consequences of it
which were that he always wanted to
cross gaps and he'll divisions and so on
there was also and most importantly the
image this is the last thing I want to
say of communication communication was I
think his answer to the main question of
his life what is a man a man a human
being is someone who has language who
communicates who speaks to other human
beings and the first destruction of
humanity and Auschwitz
Premal AV tells us in the drowned and
the saved was the Babel of languages and
also the fact that the Capo's gave
orders in a barracks German that not
even German speaking Jews could
understand so you couldn't learn from
other prisoners or very very few
especially if you're Italian and had no
Yiddish and you couldn't understand the
captors and so although people seem to
die of starvation and disease lady said
really they died of not understanding
and then when he got home all he wanted
to do was communicate his experiences
and he spent the rest of his life
communicating his experiences both to
people in his life and to us his readers
and this went very very far back in his
life right to the very first story that
he ever wanted to write perhaps as early
as school he wanted to write the story
the story of carbon the carbon atom now
this is a story of a carbon atom that
moves into living substances like leaves
and insects and then back into the raw
material of carbon over millennia and he
thought of writing the story again
in prison before Auschwitz and in in
Auschwitz itself and then finally he
wrote it in 1970 and he made it the last
chapter of his autobiography the
periodic table this is the story of an
atom as far away from himself as he
could get and then he brought it back to
himself again in the most vivid act of
communication with his reader that I
think I've ever read this is how carbon
ends the carbon atom enters a glass of
milk and the milk is drunk and the atom
enters the bloodstream of the drinker
and that enters a cell a cell in his
body and these are these are the last
lines this cell belongs to a brain and
it is my brain the brain of the me who
is writing and the cell in question and
within it the atom in question is in
charge of my writing in a gigantic
miniscule game which nobody's yet
described it is that which at this
instant emerging from a labyrinthine
Tuggle tangle of yeses and noes makes my
hand run along a certain path on the
paper and mark it with these spirals
which are signs a double leap up and
down between two levels of energy guides
this hand of mine to impress on the
paper this dot here this one and it is
as though you can touch the actual dot
that he made and I think that that is
the human touch that primal Av always
craved and only ever achieved in writing
like this and he said I am a talker if
you stop up my mouth I die and I think
it was because he could not talk at the
end he felt he could not talk he could
not write he could company not
communicate that he did die and the way
to keep alive not only the memory of
those to whom you testified but primo
leve alive himself is to go on reading
him to go on listening to him thank you
thank you
I'm sorry I've gone on awfully long are
there any questions yes yes would you
like could you wait there has been other
extensive biographies written about
primo levy how did you initially get
interested in writing the book and why
did you feel the need to write another
book about primo levy and how did you
deal with spending 10 years writing such
a wonderful book thank you well I
thought very much that another biography
of primo levy was needed there weren't
very many there were some small things
that had been written in Italy and there
was one large biography that had been
written by a French writer but you will
not be surprised if you hear me say that
I didn't think it was very good
why I came to it myself that is I think
I have to answer that autobiographically
I'm Jewish myself I am the daughter of
Viennese refugees to England and then
later to Canada where I grew up and I
think I was a pretty typical perhaps
second generation person I didn't want
to know I never read anything never read
any material on the show ever
in England I became a reviewer and I
made a virtue of necessity of my
foreignness and so I got sent all
foreign books you know if it was foreign
send it to Carol and so one day in 1989
I was sent primo Levy's last book that
round and the saved and it was I knew it
was a work of genius and that this was
some one I have to read all of him and I
have to read everything at last and live
with him for to answer the other part of
your question for eight years of
researching and writing and that's what
I did and I don't regret a minute of it
yes I'm wondering if you found in
writing the biography if you had a
phosphorus experience
that's the first question I heard in
talking to people who write biographies
that it's very difficult to eliminate
material as well as to decide what to
include right now that was a wonderfully
sort of literary symbolic question at
phosphorus experience that's to say was
there something I came across that I
felt I shouldn't put in is that what you
meant yes despite the length of my book
there is masses I didn't put in of
course it's always important to cut and
shape and I try to shape my book it's a
strange shape but that was a very
deliberate attempt to give it some kind
of you know shape of its own not just
the shape of Premo lady's life you know
I it was such a difficult and painful
life his wife and children are still
alive and although I have had to say of
course something about that it would be
very strange if I didn't I have said as
little as possible I'm sure it will
still be painful to them to read about
him although I would hope one always has
this wild hope that perhaps if they
because you know after all people within
a family they know one another probably
less well than they know anyone in the
world because we all need one another
it's all a question of need we hide we
therefore perhaps I could hope that
there's some ways in which I might a
biographer not me but a biographer might
be able to tell people in someone's life
things they didn't know and that helped
them to understand why certain things
happened and in my wildest fantasies I
imagine perhaps that could be the case
but so there were many things I didn't
put into the book yes yes
since primo Levy's pivotal experiences
were during the Holocaust do you have
any opinion of how he might have
responded to the aftermath of 9/11 as it
concerned Jews I'm thinking primarily of
the assassination of Daniel Pearl and
the homicide bombers in Israel well this
is a difficult and painful question as I
think many are questions about primo la
vie and for primo ladies are as I said
to you earlier he was passionately
deliberately self-punishing ly on tribal
he refused to you know stand in a
position of solidarity for the sake of
solidarity ever during for example in
1982 when Israel invaded Lebanon he was
one of the Italian and indeed
international Jewish intellectuals who
stood up and said that that was wrong
and that that the Israeli Defense Force
should withdraw and he got into terrible
trouble with many of his closest friends
survivors for example other survivors he
found it so painful not to stand with
them that it was one of the major
factors one of the major causes of his
1982 depression which was extremely
severe which lasted for nine months and
which nearly killed him I think
nonetheless he refused to change to say
something he didn't believe so I feel
that he would have been amongst those
who argue for a very Universalist and
non non passionately
you know tribal response to all of these
events both in America and in Israel in
internationally I'm sure that is what he
would have said does that answer your
question yes the gentleman over here
Rauch wits am I wrong in saying that I
had read that he had worked as a chemist
and I guess you explained that his
depression was basically genetic but I
don't know I guess I had surmised maybe
with a lot of other people that there
might have been the guilt of the
survivor especially if he worked as a
chemist for the Nazis is that well
incorrect no it's correct but also
incorrect let's say he did work as a
chemist in the laboratory I mean he was
in a sub-camp of Auschwitz called
bounnam on Ovitz which supplied slave
labor to the buna factory which was a
chemical factory which was supposed to
produce synthetic rubber in fact it
never did produce any synthetic rubber
because the Allies kept bombing it they
didn't bomb the railway tracks but they
bombed the the factory and it never
produced anything however the truth is
that he only became a chemist in the
laboratory for the last two months of
his time there he was there for 11
months it was only the very last period
the last two months now that did help
him to survive because it was the winter
again was you know end of 1944 beginning
of 1945 but he had survived all the rest
of the time in a different way he didn't
work for the Nazis he did nothing you
know he set up the the the equipment the
Bombers came over and they dismantled
the equipment and they came back and set
up the equipment he did nothing he even
attempted small bits of you know
sabotage and so on so we mustn't over
interpret you know his his role as a
chemist in the camp in terms of survivor
guilt of course he had survivor guilt
you everybody would have to he did feel
you know he describes terribly well how
when you are out doors in one of the
worst commandos and dying you have no
time to think of anything nothing
there's no thought that the point is
that you are driven below the
level of thought even below the level of
feeling in some sense at least human
feeling you're just dying whereas the
moment he got into the lab the moment
you are in a safer place you slightly
return to and closer to human state and
that means you start to feel all of
these feelings as well so he felt guilty
while he was in the laboratory but he
never did anything you know he wasn't
one of those of whom naturally and
inevitably there were some who survived
sometimes at the expense of others and
so on
that was never primo Levy's case he
survived in the most humane possible way
by having a friend and by sharing with
that friend every scrap that he found
Alberto de lovato whose name I've
mentioned to you
so his survivor guilt was you know
generic if you like and because he spent
his whole life now you imagine this at
the age of 27 he comes back from the
camp in October 1945 he sits down in
December and writes that book I mean he
wrote it immediately immediately it was
published in 1947 he began to testify
from the start and he never stopped and
he went to schools in Italy and spoke to
the students all the way through from
the mid 60's to the mid 70s he wrote
about it he talked about it all his life
so his survivor guilt was as it were
transformed and risen above to some
extent it's true that whenever he had a
very severe depression a certain guilt
would return about a particular person
with whom he had not shared a drop of
water that he had found but I am
convinced that this guilt was a an
effect or a symptom of his depression
rather than a cause of it or I think we
have to stop but I'm happy to talk later
on to anybody who
carol-anne Jerez author of the double
bond
primo levia biography it's published by
Fair Straus and Giroux on the web at FSG
books calm
next week on public lives John